in a stunning move to limit immigration
President Trump is setting to challenge
a 150 year old constitutional standard
that anyone born in America is an
American citizen the president tells the
political website
Axios that he plans to sign an executive
order to quote remove the right to
citizenship for babies of non-citizens
and unauthorized immigrants born on US
soil
now how ridiculous were the only country
in the world where a person comes in has
a baby and the baby is essentially a
citizen of the United States for 85
years with all of those benefits it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous and it has to
end
have you talked about that with counsel
yeah I have so we're in the process it's
in the process it'll happen we've got an
executive order that's what you're
talking about yes exactly I didn't think
anybody but knew that but me I thought I
was the only one the 14th amendment
passed after the Civil War specifically
says this all persons born or
naturalized in the United States are
citizens the Supreme Court has upheld
this rule for a legal permanent
residents but has never decided as
citizenship case involving an illegal
immigrant or a short-term visitor to the
US